ok ok ok on est parti en hiver de quoi
on se parle aujourd'hui on se parle de
ce smartphone à smartphone là c'est le
xiaomi on se tait pro leur ont jeté pro
et sa sortie il ya quelques mois je me
suis dit tiens alors que le ch et howie
12 va être officialisée en europe d'ici
très peu de temps est ce que selon ses
propos le coup est ce qu'il est encore
intéressant aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il
faut venir se positionner est-ce que
vous devez encore si vous voulez si vous
fait de l'oeil est-ce que vous pouvez
encore venir vous positionner sur ce
smartphone là sur le chien au mieux on
se tait pro ou alors est-ce qu'il faut
oublier c'est ce qu'on va venir regarder
aujourd'hui on va venir regarder c'est
toujours intéressant au niveau de la
performance au niveau de la photo est ce
qu'il tient toujours ses promesses et
puis surtout qu'est ce qu'il en est du
prix parce qu'on sait que les prix des
smartphones ce soit sous android ou sur
un os c'est encore plus vrai sur android
et bien chute assez rapidement donc
regarder aujourd'hui tout de suite début
2022 parce que ce chiot me on se tait
pro est intéressant ou alors pas dû
[Musique]
regardez pour moi le premier tout ça
c'est juste ici au niveau du cou parce
que ce smartphone là quand il est sorti
il y avait deux config il ya des 8 gigas
de ram de tous les côtés on avait soit
du 8 plus 128 soit du 8 + 2 156 hockey
jusque là ça vous aura pas échappé
attention ici non extensible on peut pas
venir à bout des cartes microsd c'était
déjà un truc un petit peu mais on peut
dire que ça fait râler c'est pas tout
nouveau aujourd'hui beaucoup de
constructeurs qu'ils le font mais voilà
c'était comme ça alors quand il est
sorti ce smartphone à 828 écouter ce que
nous disent pas de bêtises
669 euros 90 et lorsqu'il est sorti en
version 8 256 il coûtait
699 euros 98 quasiment 700 euros sauf
qu'aujourd'hui ce smartphone est bien il
a chuté de pris un petit peu c'est à
dire que au lieu de le faire à
669 90 sont là tombé à 5 169 90 on a
gagné 100 euros et c'est exactement la
même chose sur l'autre confie on le
touche aujourd'hui à 599 euros 90 sur le
site de shiomi d'ailleurs si vous
intéresse vous amis des liens en bas
dans la description bon c'est vrai que
c'est intéressant c'était déjà un très
joli smartphone quand il a été présenté
au mois de septembre ou octobre 2021 il
y avait une très jolie proposition mais
là déjà quand on sait qu'on gagne 100
euros quelques mois plus tard
franchement ça vaut le coup sûr du neuf
on se parle vraiment de 9 et si vous le
trouvez reconditionnés ou pour les
trouver que probablement encore un peu
moins cher mais j'ai pas été voir donc
là c'est vraiment tout cas intéressant
alors qu'est ce qu'il raconte ce
smartphone est bien déjà ce qu'on voit
c'est qu'il n'a pas trop vieilli en
termes de look il reste vraiment très
actuel très joli j'adore l'emplacement
du module photo alors s'il pas parfait
mais j'aime bien l'idée en tout cas de
cette gamme qu'on avait en 2021 que je
trouve toujours très actuel en 2020 donc
ça m'irait très bien toujours très
profilé toujours très sympa vous venez
de recharge à ici alors la recherche
d'un des points extrêmement forts de ce
smartphone pourquoi parce que vous avez
une recherche 120 watts ou c'était la
promesse 120 watts à dire que vous leur
charge et de 2 à 100% en 17 minutes en
17 minutes 2-2 à 100% pourquoi est-ce
qu'on part pas de zéro et 2 2 c'est le
temps qui viennent goûter pascal mettre
un peu plus de temps donc dès qu'il est
bouté qu'il ait démarré qu'il a ses deux
premiers pourcents de recharger en 17
minutes en 120 watts actuellement le
seul smartphone star le marché qui est
vraiment intéressant qui va recharger
aussi rapidement pour autant y rassurez
vous c'est pas du 120 watts constante
qu'on va pas venir flinguer sa batterie
et monde ici en bleu la coupe de
puissance du téléphone en rouge sang les
pourcentages en fonction du temps qu'on
a commencé à 2% jusqu'au sang pour sang
le sang pour cent affichée sur le
téléphone arrive en 18 minutes on n'est
pas mal quand même par rapport aux deux
sélections 17 minutes communiqué par
chéreau mais on est on est on est plutôt
pas mal mais on a du coup un pic ici à
120 watts comme convenu mais qui est
relativement court de quelques secondes
on n'est pas sans mandat soit 118 sans
lequel qu'on est vraiment exactement on
est un petit peu en dessous on est ici
voilà le pic est à 114,10 a donc ensuite
voilà ça décroît rita petit ensuite nous
arriver aux 100 % affichée par téléphone
on observe encore de la puissance qui
arrive dans téléphone jusqu'à ici dans
de 2 à 100% réellement réellement vie
seven de livres d'accord mais lui il
affiche 2 à 100% en 17/18 affiché sur le
téléphone et voilà en fait on a une
différence entre ce qui est affiché par
téléphone et ce qui est réellement
encore accessible dans la batterie une
fois qu'on a passé le pic de charge
décharge à combien à peu près donc on a
un premier plateau qui est à 95 watts
quand même ça des croix pour arriver un
second plateau qui est aux alentours des
70 cette voie là sachant qu'aujourd'hui
les plus gros chargeurs qui sortent ans
et 60 cents quoi donc en fait là c'est
quand même pas mal d'avoir des deux
plateaux aussi aulas on a un autre qui
est à 64 hockey ensuite
parce que j'ai toujours trouvé très très
actuelle cet écran il ya une super dalle
une très très belle dalle oled elle est
vraiment bien bien calibré super boulot
de chien omis là dessus et une fois de
plus que ce soit en 2021 2022 ça ira
parfaitement bien elle était très bien
calibrée en 2021 elle est toujours
autant 2020 200 on s'en doutera doc a
pas de changement là dessus pour les sur
du full hd plus on est sur un smartphone
comme je vous dis aux alentours de 600
700 euros donc n'a pas de souci
là-dessus taux de rafraîchissement de
120 hertz donc ça c'est avec c'est un
truc qui est aussi super cool 100 verte
adaptatif personnellement il vient
cocher les cases sur ce qu'on peut faire
en 2022 la plupart des smartphones haut
de gamme vont rester sur du sang versé
il y en aura peut-être quelques uns sur
244 m mais ça reste minime on se
retrouve ici avec du 120 hertz adaptatif
ça ira très bien en 2022 tout comme
c'était très bien en 2020 internes ont
pour moi ce qu'ils proposent ici au
niveau de l'écran sur du dolby vision
avec un corning gorilla glass virtus qui
vient vraiment le protéger un milliard
de couleurs hdr 10 plus et un taux
d'échantillonnage tactile de 491 pour le
gaming et bien on a un truc qui va
extrêmement bien et qui continuera de
séduire en tout cas pour cette première
partie d'année demi 22 attendons de voir
ce qui arrivera du côté du xiaomi 12t
promis 2022 mais pour l'instant début
2022 celui-là je peux vous assurer
qu'ils cachent encore toutes les cases
au niveau de l'écran il ya aucun
problème mais vous savez je vous le dis
souvent vos smartphones penser à venir
les protéger notamment avec les codes de
mon partenaire rhino chine et c'est
marrant parce que regarder j'arrive sur
le site de rhinau shit qu'est ce que je
vois que pour la série xiaomi 11 tg des
coques et si je regarde en plus ici haut
niveau ces housses et de la boutique eh
bien regardez il m'affiche shiomi 12
alors on n'y est pas il va être annoncé
il va être proposé mais si je la
regardais par curiosité parce que je
trouve ça vraiment rigolo eh bien je
vois que je peux choisir mon chiot
midouze et que je peux venir déjà
inscrire à la newsletter pour savoir
quand les produits liés aux chaumes et
12 vont arriver donc ça c'est plutôt
bien alors même si on parle pas tout de
suite du show me douche on se parle
effectivement du onze type rose par le
duo on se tait et puis on se parle de
beaucoup de produits de chimie donc si
vous avez un smartphone de chez omis ou
encore d'autres marques via vous pouvez
y retrouver votre bonheur ici que se
fasse sur des coques prévenir également
les personnaliser des protections
d'écran mais également des câbles est ce
que je vais vous montrer sur la
personnalisation c'est hyper hyper canon
parce qu'ils ont plein de collaborations
intéressantes dans plein d'univers
différents alors il ya des nouvelles
vous avez dû snoopy bray du monde à
laurianne dragon ball dragon ball z ya
les lakers ici avec la nba on va voir du
disney classique ce g2 esport one piece
la taille des titans batna van gogh
museum marvel harry potter disney pixar
bref y en a des tonnes des tonnes et des
tonnes je vous laisse regarder n'oubliez
pas que si vous voulez prouver votre
protection pour votre smartphone pour
vos xiaomi 11 tu es pro aux meilleurs
prix chez rhinochill vous avez avec le
code greu 22 - 5 % de remise pour bien
protéger que ce soit au niveau de votre
solide suite au niveau de votre coque au
niveau de votre protection d'écran
également au niveau de vos câbles et
compagnie donc ça c'est vachement bien
donc on a vu qu'ici au niveau de l'écran
il était parfaitement cohérent très bons
débuts 2022 après il ya un truc qui est
intéressant si vous êtes un gamer je
sais pas si c'est votre cas alors dites
le moi en bas en commentaire ici vous
avez un moteur de vibrations va faire
vibrer votre smartphone lorsque vous
allez jouer dont vous aurez un petit
retour lorsque vous jouez à des jeux ou
fait tirer dessus les compagnies alors
moi je suis pas hyper hyper fan il y en
a plein qui aime bien donc si c'est
votre cas eh bien vous aurez vraiment un
truc intéressant je vous dis est
vraiment orienté gaming avec ce bel
écran le taux de rafraîchissement du
taux d'échantillonnage tactile le moteur
vibrations et la performance parce que
même si on n'a pas le dernier processeur
qui était présenté en décembre 2021
c'est normal puisqu'il est sorti quand
même me 2021 celui-là on a quand même le
processeur le plus puissant de l'année
dernière le sandre agon 888 gravées en
50 nanomètres qui reste extrêmement
performant donc en termes de gaming pour
moi ça va ça fonctionne en termes de
fluidité parce que le processeur et la
portera pas uniquement de la puissance
brute lorsque vous allez venir jouer à
des jeux mais il servira également pour
de la photo parce que lorsqu'on veut
faire une photo vous déclenchez tout
vous déclenchez le processeur le gpu les
capteurs bref tout tourne tout est
allumée pour qu'il faut de la puissance
de calcul derrière en plus de sa région
où il adore faire ça si vous laissez
montrer les muscles et montrer la
puissance vous avez 8 gigas de ram c'est
la lpddr2 5 ok nickel et la techno de
stockage que vous et derrière comme ça
sur 128 ou 256 élus ffs 3.0 comptable de
lecture et d'écriture ça ira bien donc
il est une fois de plus extrêmement
cohérent et puis ce qui est bien c'est
qu'on a cette grosse batterie de 5000
milliampères heures alors ok 5 millions
père heures c'est beau c'est gros dans
ce positionnement là haut niveau ce
smartphone sera parfaitement bien par
contre si vous restez sur du 120 hertz
il ya un moment ça veut dire poussé un
petit peu mais le truc vachement
rassurant c'est que comme ce smartphone
là vous venez de recharger qu'un bug de
charge 120 watts vous avez pas besoin de
le charger de 0 à 100% vous ne gardez
toujours entre 1 20 et 1 81% vous le
branchez vous mettez une petite charge
de 10 minutes et c'est monde est reparti
pour un jour et demi deux jours c'est
vachement cool on doit tous les cas on
est rassurés et c'est ça qui me plaît
bien parce qu'on va beaucoup de
smartphones vont sortir en 2022 avec de
la charge 65 watts de la charge 25 rois
de la charge 45 watts on pourrait avoir
également aussi la charge 120 watts mais
là ils sont en avance par rapport à 2022
donc c'est très cool et c'est très
rassurante vous rechargez vite et vous
êtes partis dans tous les cas même si
vous manquez d'autonomie vous êtes bon
vous le branchez vous laisser cinq dix
minutes et vous les parties jusqu'à la
fin de votre journée très facilement
alors il ya un autre truc qu'on va me
regarder de plus près c'est toute la
partie photo lors la partie photo elle
intéressante pourquoi parce que vous
avez déjà un capteur grand temps que
votre capteur principal 500 8 mégapixels
permettra à faire pas mal de choses en
conditions de faible luminosité de
regrouper plusieurs pixels en un seul
pixel pour vous sortir des photos en 12
mégapixels qui auront capter beaucoup de
luminosité et qu'ils seront très bonne
notamment pour la photo nuit donc dans
l'idée pourquoi pas par contre je trouve
qu'à côté il est un peu moins bon au
niveau du grand-angle sur un 8
mégapixels mais on va la garder ça dans
quelques instants il ya de la macro
ouais 5 mégapixels moi ça ne vends pas
du rêve c'est à dire que le sang de 8
mégapixels il ya aucun problème ça me
plaît bien le 8 on va regarder ça le 5
c'est pas ouf j'aurais aimé que sur un
modèle pro on nous met un téléobjectif
clairement pour moi ça avait un sens
alors effectivement vous le dirai avec
le son du méga pixels pour venir
chercher des choses en images ouais mais
c'est du numérique c'est pas de
l'optique donc bon moi c'est un modèle
pro donc ça ça me ça me moque pas des
masses à côté de ça vous effectivement
une caméra celles fixées aux mégapixels
à l'avant broc et pourquoi pas on peut
bien faire une petite photo de cette
fille je vous montre le résultat vous
êtes tous vraiment quelques instants on
peut venir filmer huit cas 30 images par
seconde pas convaincu non plus je pense
que la 4k 60 suffira largement ici il
montre les muscles je suis on me l'a dit
donc une fois de plus attendez quelques
centres parce que je veux montrer le
résultat mais en termes de photos ce qui
est vraiment intéressant sur ce
smartphone là je pense que c'est le
capteur de 8 mégapixels mais je reste un
peu sur ma faim sur un smartphone qui
même si tout de suite les tarifs ont un
peu baissé voyez il était quand même à
700 euros est quasiment 700 euros ne pas
voir de tels objectifs pour moi c'était
pas beau et c'était dommage il avait
tellement plein de belles qualités à
côté au niveau de cette charge rapide au
niveau de ce processeur haut niveau de
cet écran je trouve que je suis aurait
pu aller un peu plus loin au niveau de
la photo mais c'était parce qu'il
voulait faire peut-être qu'ils sont dit
c'est parce que valent nos utilisateurs
donc la photo on fera un truc bien que
108 après le rsa va être pas mal mais
c'est pas dingue et ça c'est un peu
dommage une fois de plus en mal de
résultats dans quelques instants reste à
lhassa smartphone qu'on peut trouver son
miel 12.5 avec un android 11 alors il
sera très actuel également avec le nfc
pour le paiement dématérialisé mais ça
rien de bien neuf il ya du wifi 6 ok pas
du 6e mais combien de smartphones ont dû
6e en 2022 pas des masses donc ce sera
largement suffisant ce que j'ai regretté
et je vous le dit tout à l'heure c'est
que vous n'avez pas d'extension de
cartes mémoires on a déjà 128 et 256 1
globalement je pense qu'il ya de quoi
faire et puis il n'a pas de
certification et ça c'est qu'ils
comparent je veux dire on un smartphone
a quasiment 700 euros on n'a aucune
certification d'étanchéité alors on
pourrait se dire ok ok ok ok ok je me
doute que ce smartphone est étanche je
me dis shiomi a voulu tirer les prix au
plus bas et c'est la politique de la moi
de dire ok on propose des tarifs les
plus justes avec les marges les plus
faibles pour être extrêmement compétitif
et faire plaisir à nos clients mais je
sais pas une fois de plus à 600 700
euros je m'attends à voir un smartphone
qui est certifié résistant à l'eau et à
la poussière je ne doute pas qu'il le
soit mais il n'est pas certifié en tout
cas c'est un peu dommage vous le voyez
fait pas mieux le journée qui est passé
entre le moment où j'ai tourné la vidéo
et le moment où je montre sa barbe il
est parti faire des photos en espagne
pour un autre projet mais c'est une
autre histoire je voulais vous montrer
mais rapidement les photos faites avec
ceux ci a omis on se tait pro parce
qu'effectivement il est très bon sur le
capteur principal sur son 8 mégapixels
si on vient trop zoomer c'est pas où
vous allez barclays ultra-grand-angle
est pas parfait regardez là on accepte
ou qui sont en fait aussi 8 mégapixels
je trouve que dans l'ensemble le rendu
est vraiment bien l'ultra grand temps où
vous le voyez là on perd des gens en
précision ses homologues sont moins
contrasté et la colorimétrie beaucoup
moins bonnes la voyance les photos pour
zoomer à partir du sol 8 mégapixels
parce qu'à pas de tels objectifs et on
se rend compte déjà une perte de qualité
on le voit au niveau de la peau et vous
avez requiert beaucoup de bruit
lorsqu'on vient zoom est donc un
traitement qui est pas souffler dessus
qu'on a ici alors après ces logiciels ça
peut être corrigée en fonction des mises
à jour donc là dessus c'est pas le truc
le plus problématique mais malgré tout
la qualité que vous allez perdre 11 ou
mais elle est là elle est comme ça voilà
peut pas changer l'histoire la jument
des photos qui ont été fait la nuit là
on est sur l'ultra grand temps qu'on
voit qu'il ya beaucoup d'imprécisions
sur les côtés là c'est vraiment pas
dingue vous allez voir qu'il ya beaucoup
de bruits qui ressort en règle générale
là par exemple c'est très compliqué
parce que la voyons d une grosse source
de lumière va il en a pas on a vraiment
du bruit sur le côté qu'on va retrouver
également par ici voyez là c'est pareil
on est venu nous met dans l'image et du
bruit ici du bruit par ci du bruit par
là des photos au lever du soleil si
pareille très imprécis ultra-grand-angle
on repère tout de suite c'est vraiment
pas une qualité extraordinaire et là on
vient et zoomer on a du bruit c'est
vraiment un peu le problème on le voit
qu'on n'est pas sur un photophone on est
sur un smartphone qui fait des photos
qui est pas mal qui sera bon sur le
sauriez mégapixels on peut venir vous
aimez regarder c'est vraiment pas beau
du tout donc ça on va complètement
oublié mais si vous êtes 108 mégapixels
n'y a pas de fioritures vous n'êtes pas
en train de vous ne vous êtes pas sur
les travaux tant le rendu est vraiment
très bon et là ça marche la regardez là
on a des photos que son 100e médias
pixels et vous avec les conditions là
sont vraiment parfaite trouver photo un
peu froide peut-être qu'ici au niveau
des hautes lumières sur le côté c'est un
poil cramer c'est pas parfait mais le
rendu est vraiment correct par contre le
mode portrait je trouve vraiment pas
dingue hein parce que il ya un côté qui
est vraiment artificielle et on le voit
au niveau des oreilles l'envoyé des
tours palles assez floue voilà c'est pas
c'est pas un truc qui est d'1 go ça pour
moi c'est oublier la caméra de celle
fille si on vous positionner bien avec
le soleil en face de vous elle fera le
job la solide et sur le côté c'est très
poussif sait pas où et à contre-jour bon
ça marche pas ne va pas trop lui en
vouloir c'est une caméra selphy par
contre dès lors que vous avez le soleil
sur vous à la ça fonctionne beaucoup
mieux alors c'est pas parfait mais c'est
une caméra de celle fille et on lui en
voudra pas trop aimé lorsque vous êtes
sur votre sang 8 mégapixels bonne
condition qu'elle la lumière regarder le
résultat est vraiment magnifique je
trouve très bon je vous dis une fois de
plus au niveau des hautes lumières il
sera pas parfait mais au fait des choses
pas mal l'ultra grand angle forcément
lorsqu'un beaucoup lumière celle optique
c'est de la photo ça ira mieux même si
une fois de plus c'est pas parfait et
notamment ici sur les contours on peut
venir se rapprocher zoom et un peu ma
tension on y va mollo mollo mais
globalement
il fera le boulot il ya tout qui m'a
surpris c'est la macro original je suis
pas fan de la macro sur les smartphones
je trouve qu'ici le rendu est pas
mauvais pas c'est pas non plus un truc
absolument dingue on peut bien faire un
peu de macros pour autant y at il
réellement des usages derrière je ne
pense pas je pense qu'en fait sur son
smartphone vers vous les 3 capteurs y en
a un qui est vraiment intéressant c'est
le sens 8 mégapixels on vient pas trop
journée on fait des photos
tranquillement c'est mignon ça marche
bien et ça c'est cool le reste c'est
plus gadget est une fois de plus c'est
un smartphone qui est orienté
performance mais pas particulièrement
photos on peut pas tout avoir en tout
cas pas sur ce smartphone
faire une petite vidéo comme ça
directement takkal un produit sont en
espagne on est assis jet on est venu
tourner ici on vous dira pas pourquoi on
saura plus tard mais on regarde quand
même que leur donnent toujours cette
caméra en 2022 est ce qu'elle vaut
toujours le coup fort alors grave et la
gauche c'est comme ça on va te tape à
contre jour on va regarder comment elle
gère le changement lumière parce que ça
viendrait ce qu'elle fait la gueule mais
je ne doute pas que sur ce smartphone à
ça fonctionne alors après on n'est pas
non plus sur un vidéophone mais pour
autant le boulot et et là on se fait
avec l' ultra grand-angle on a un peu
plus de place alors fatalement c'est sûr
ça sera moins bon que soit votre grand
angle mais vous n'arrivez à rien et sa
sympathie pas sûr qu'il faille utiliser
ultra-grand-angle pour de la vidéo plus
pour la photo bien qu'ils soient pas
parfait mais malgré tous on veut élargir
l'espace on peut le faire on peut aussi
faire de la vidéo comme ça dans cette
fille si vous voulez vous voir comme ça
dans le moniteur avoir un petit retour
on peut le faire on s'est fixé sur ce ne
serait pas la meilleure caméra mais pour
venir l'utiliser comme ça en tout cas de
ce que je vois ça m'a l'air pas mal ça a
l'air bien stabilisé et je pense qu'il
fait le taf ouais alors après il est un
peu plus de mal forcément si je me bats
contre jour mais comme ça regardez le
boulot est fait ça marche pas ça
smartphones que j'aime beaucoup et que
je trouve intéressant il est pas parfait
schumi a dû arbitrer des trois c'est
évident lorsqu'on a créé un smartphone
et qu'on veut être au plus juste au
niveau du tarif en souvenez-vous
quasiment 700 euros aujourd'hui on est
quand même un peu en dessous 100 euros
de moins c'est vachement bien d'élus
2022 puis je pense qu'il va continuer à
descendre donc une fois de plus si vous
regardez cette vidéo plus tard dans
l'année et bien regardez les prix les
prix ont dû chuter c'est vachement bien
c'est un excellent smartphone pour tout
l'aspect multimédia pour venir visionner
des films visionner des séries pour
venir jouer pour du gaming on a vraiment
un excellent produit la dalle et hop ya
beaucoup de performance qui reste très
actuelle en 2022 les restaurations toute
la première partie de l'année je pense
qu'il sera encore bon deuxième partie de
l'année même si d'ici là d'autres
modèles sont sortis et les tarifs auront
baissé donc il sera probablement un peu
disqualifié au niveau du tarif et de la
concurrence mais me 2022 par contre pour
tout ce qui est photo il est pas mal
mais ce n'est qu'à ce tarif là on peut
trouver bien meilleur photophone donc si
vous voulez un très joli smartphone
plutôt accès multimédia plutôt axé
gaming la performance brute chez aux
murs les pros et très cool si vous
voulez un photophone à 600 euros c'est
pas celui là qu'il nous faudra il est
très bien il n'est pas parfait et il
n'est pas équilibré mais il ya un autre
pan que j'adore et qu'un très gros point
fort ce smartphone est qu une des
raisons pour laquelle il faut venir
acheter cette recharge extrêmement
rapide parce que même si un moment vous
jouez beaucoup regardé beaucoup de
séries et vous tapez vraiment dans
niveau de la batterie vous le branchez
dix minutes et vous autres partis et 10
minutes si vous vous rendez compte de 2
à 100% en 17 minutes voilà bravo donc
j'aime bien a vous de me dire ce que
vous en pensez en banque au motif moi
vous trouvez ce shiomi on se tait pro
est ce que il peut vous tentez en 2022
est ce que vous l'avez acheté en 2021 et
si c'est le cas est-ce que vous en êtes
satisfait c'est toujours bien d'avoir en
retour d'expérience et de venir partager
en bas dans les commentaires sur ce je
vous embrasse vous dis à très bientôt
pour le soin de vous des bisous beaucoup
d'amour à bientôt qu'un
[Musique]